for example your living situation as you
were riding Rocky you painted the
windows block to focus yeah I did paint
in Black because I don't know what time
it didn't matter what time it was oh
it's time for breakfast right away
you've just you derailed yourself I'll
have breakfast and I'm hungry I don't
need to know what time right that kind
of thing so I was trying to eliminate
all the excuses because it's hard to
write you're looking for any reason
please someone call that's why I took
the phone out but writing I'll tell you
right now is a miserable means of
existence it is terrible is there
anything you like about no there's
nothing you love you love the end result
you love the fact you have it on paper
look at writers yeah it's all worn out
they're tired they live in their own
heads no because again I tell young
people that want to be writers don't get
so hung up on the Perfection know that
90 of it is garbage ninety percent of
the writers they go up to about page 90
burn out they don't have that finale if
you happen to have an ending man you're
home free